O podría el partido encontrar unanimidad
en torno a la candidatura de baile o la
preocupación por su estado de salud crea
más dudas que certezas
Bueno buenas noches Yo creo que va a ser
difícil para
yopal unir el partido Cuando llegamos
más cerca de las elecciones en este
momento él tiene que decir que va a
seguir como su candidato porque estamos
muy cercanos a nuestras elecciones
congresionales muy importantes y él no
puede causar
caos en el partido Demócrito y también
tiene dos años y más de dos años de su
periodo y el momento que dice que no va
a ser candidato va a disminuir su poder
y en caso de que finalmente bailen no
fuera candidato podrían llamar a Harris
o alguna otra figura tener la suficiente
fuerza como para enfrentarse a Donald
Trump
yo creo que sí yo creo que primero va a
ser una pelea dentro del partido
demócrata muy fuerte y yo normalmente un
vicepresidente como es la señora Harris
tendría una ventaja pero en este momento
la señora Harris no es muy fuerte y
políticamente no es no hay aceptación
dentro
muy fuerte tanto del partido pero al fin
y al cabo cualquier puede derrotar a
Donald Trump y todavía no estamos seguro
que con trampas el candidato tampoco
claro Donald Trump todavía no ha
ratificado no ha dicho que se vaya a
presentar abrimos el debate a la
política en general de Estados Unidos
tanto en el partido demócrata como en el
republicano parece que las figuras de
más edad dominan el campo político
necesitaría Estados Unidos un cambio
generacional en su política
yo creo que sí yo creo que es muy
importante y además voces llamando para
un cambio de generación
si ve muchos de los candidatos fuertes
no solo yo bailén sino
todos son de una generación mucho mayor
y el mismo en el partido republicano
creo que yo creo que estamos en un punto
de cambio intergeneracional Esta es la
generación de Segunda Guerra Mundial y
de Vietnam y creo que necesitamos más
jóvenes ahora en el en la pelea y yo
creo que vamos a ver en las próximas
elecciones